juste en face du château construit par
louis 11
l'industriel tutoie désormais le
spirituel 4ds capote ds
autant travail dans la cap pour le jeux
de textures ça marcherait et là il nous
faudra du structurel donc plutôt inox ou
assis
ce saint martin de 7 mètres sur 7 sera
le plus grand de l'histoire il porte en
lui les valeurs le partage mais aussi
plus actuel le recyclage on travaille
exclusivement avec de la récup parce
qu'on pourrait être moins intrusif
possible au niveau de l'environnement et
puis pour les jeux de textures comme on
peut observer là dessus c'est notre note
est motif pour éviter de justement de
travailler avec des produits
manufacturés un peu trop un peu trop dur
au niveau de l'environnement quoi le
propriétaire du château avait déjà
fabriqué le cheval deux artistes de
loges sont venu finir le travail le
saint le mendiant et le manque d'eau
c'est comme un puzzle en fait on a on a
plein de pièces autour de nous et puis à
nous de trouver où ça va se placer et
puis c'est vraiment une question de
oued d'oeil on est toujours à regarder à
prendre du recul et puis elle se dire
vrai ça ça marche nickel a laissé partir
d'alcool
[Musique]
louis 11 était très attaché à saint
martin à l'époque c'était le pèlerinage
le plus couru stéphane veut participer à
son nouvel élan quand on regarde le
détail du visage par exemple de saint
martin on voit l'expression l'expression
qui est grave parce que il fait froid
c'est l'hiver il voit un mendiant qui
lui fait de la peine et est donc ils
découpent son manteau il ya voilà on est
dans une dans une compassion et puis de
l'autre côté on voit le le le mendiant
qui appelle qui implore qui a froid qui
qui qui est dans une misère dans une
détresse donc cette symbolique du
partage de les changes
finalement c'est ce qu'on a retrouvé
avec les artistes prochaine étape montée
l'évêque de tours sur son cheval avant
l'été les pèlerins de la route de saint
martin pourront venir lui rendre visite